Listen to me.
Pain is temporary.
It may last for a minute or an hour or a day or even a year.
But eventually it will subside and something else will take its place.
If I quit however, it will last forever.
You're all spoiled.
Some of you are spoiled.
It's just bottom line, your parents have done everything for you.
You never had to do nothing for yourself.
You're spoiled.
We're gonna keep it real tonight.
Some of you are spoiled brats.
Every time you ever got in trouble, somebody in your house got you out of it.
Every time you've done something you're not supposed to do, people say,...
..."Eric, your mother is a tyrant."
You're right!
She kicked me out.
She's mean, but she developed a man.
Because she put me out there and said, "You're gonna have to grow up!"
And some of you have never learned to grow up.
And so every time something get hard, you quit, you call momma.
I dare you to take a little pain.
I dare you.
I dare you not to go home.
Somebody said, "I've gotta go home, I feel bad."
Go through it.
You ain't gonna die.
At the end of pain is success.
You're not going to die because you feel a little pain.
I'm not eating like I eat at home.
That's why you're about to go to the next level,...
...because if you keep eating like you eat at home,...
...you'll keep being a boy or a girl.
It's time to become man, woman.
But I'm exactly where I want to be,...
...because I realize I got to commit my very being to this thing.
I gotta breathe it, I gotta eat it, I gotta sleep it.
And until you get there, you'll never be successful in life.
But once you get there, I guarantee you the world is yours.
So, work hard and you can have whatever it is you want.